it is a great pleasure to be here with
Annalee Nuits recording this episode
episode number 22 I believe of the
arthur c-- clark center for the human
imagination
studies we do at UCSD it's one of the
few if only podcast in the UC system and
we're really delighted to have guests
like Anna Leon because you really embody
the the living spirit of our of our
prototype founder who namesake of the
Center arthur c clarke and that you are
one of the you know foremost science
fiction authors who's also very well
versed in in hard science science fact
as well as science fiction so welcome
Anna Leigh it's great to have you here
yeah thanks for having me
so last week you're on campus down here
and you were participating in an event
called your dystopia has been canceled
and this podcast was really supposed to
be filmed last weekend the day that you
were here in San Diego but in addition
to the dystopia your flight got canceled
so what actually happened and why we
didn't get to to proceed the event with
the with the podcast but nevertheless
you can find Anneliese entire entire
lecture and presentation from the Clark
center at film last week on our youtube
channel arthur c-- clark center for
human imagination i want to introduce an
elite just for the few of you who may
not know who she is quite renowned in
many different circles and i think
that's what your kind of poly
mathematical nature is what really
intrigued me about you Annalee Nuits
write science fiction and nonfiction
she's the author of the novel anima s'
nominated for the nebula and locus
Awards and she won the lambda literary
award as a science journalist she's
written for The Washington Post Slate
Ars Technica
The New Yorker and the Atlantic among
others she is also the co-host of the
podcast our opinions are correct she was
the founder of io9 which is an extremely
popular site online and she served as
the editor-in-chief of Gizmodo really
phenomenal one thing we're gonna talk
about today is not only her current
novel autonomous but her upcoming novel
and
a work of science nonfiction coming
after that so there's really no stopping
and late seams and so I wanted to start
off with with kind of a little deep dive
if you will for those of us who are
writers aspiring writers etc how you
actually create worlds in a book like
autonomous that you create you create
entire scenarios futures and
visualizations of the future that are
very crisp and realistic and yet that's
a skill it's very far removed from there
very very few writers who can switch
between nonfiction and fiction so
effortlessly so what how do you
accomplish that how do you you know is
there a way that your non-fiction
training as a science journalist etc
that informs it or is it completely
different skill sets and you're just
unique and we should just clone you
[Laughter]
interesting but you know it really is
the case that I'm using kind of the same
skill set I feel like because especially
an autonomous like a lot of the world
building and that came directly out of a
book that I had done previously a
nonfiction book about how humans might
survive a mass extinction using
technology green technology and a lot of
other things and also just the work that
I've done over the past you know 15
years covering technology and especially
covering hacking and covering
biotechnology there's a lot of
characters in the novel who are hackers
or one of the characters is a robot who
of course can naturally break into
systems because you know she just uses
her brain to connect up the system and
tries to figure out a way to fool it and
so you know I I approached fiction often
the same way I do nonfiction I interview
a lot of scientists social scientists as
well and try to get AI I want my science
to be as accurate as possible I think
that's fun and fiction writers will
often talk about how one of the best
things about fiction in some ways is
having constraints on what you're doing
of course there's the joy of making up
whatever [ __ ] you want it's delightful
but it's also fun to have some
boundaries so that you can that helps
you get more creative and so for me the
boundary is often can I make this feel
plausible is this based on technology
that's happening that's being developed
now and that might plausibly go in this
direction of course you can't predict
what's going to happen in 150 years
there's a million black swans that could
happen there's the three-body problem we
just don't know what's gonna really
happen but we can make educated guesses
and often time those often times those
educated guesses come from looking at
history and looking at how technology
has developed over time and kind of
saying all right we see certain ways
that it goes governments will intervene
in this way people will take up the
technology and do things they're not
supposed to with it which is my favorite
part too when people do that
and so I definitely I find that what
happens is I'll do a certain amount of
nonfiction and then I get a hankering to
kind of take it into the fictional arena
and then vice versa like I'll get sick
of doing fiction and I'm like god I just
want to interview a million scientists
and prent and present what they've
learned so so it's good for me because I
can kind of switch back and forth can
you have elements of both you know I'm
writing nonfiction you know I often felt
like I could manipulate past history for
people especially that are dead by kind
of putting my mind and in the mind of
these historical figures and trying to
you know analyze them psychoanalytically
but but do you feel like when you're
doing a fictional sequence that you're
training as journalists for example I
mean are you visualizing it as a
narrator you know in that perspective
like what would it be like to be a
journalist in an alternative future and
you know happening as you do an
autonomous or maybe in the deep past as
you're doing for your upcoming novel had
it can you can you switch into the kind
of journalistic mode in a fictional
setting or are they basically
non-overlapping I think you can for sure
and I actually have written I did write
a short story that was just a fake
nonfiction science piece of work of
science journalism which was about
how scientists discover how to
communicate with ants and I just wrote
it as like a future journalist covering
this discovery and talking to the
different scientists who'd worked on it
and stuff like that and that was really
fun because I got to just pretend that I
was writing journalism and so there's
some things that you don't have to do
when you're writing journalism that you
do when you're writing fiction so it's
like oh I don't really have to develop
this character so that's that's
delightful so I think you can and I
definitely in my fiction even when I'm
not pretending to be a journalist I like
to get I like my visuals to help readers
understand how science is being done and
so oftentimes like when I was doing
autonomous I talked to some
neuroscientists about just if you were
looking at neurons changing what does
that look like is it fast can you see
them doing it what is that you know what
do you see when you look through the
microscope and they told me and I put
that in the book I mean the characters
are looking at a hologram instead of
looking through a microscope and it's
the same thing it's just projected what
the microscope is seeing and indeed you
can see neurons changing in real time
growing and forming connections so which
is pretty creepy and awesome and and so
yeah I like to have journalistic detail
like I like to have you know readers
kind of come away with a sense that
things are more complicated than you
might expect and that's of course the
job of science journalism a lot of the
time is to say like well you thought the
black holes work like this but actually
no one really agrees but we do have a
picture that was today's news excited
that's all right the first black hole
selfie if only it were selfie that would
be amazing I've heard and said you know
that science fiction writers often will
contend that you know science deep
science fiction in the future is really
just kind of a manifestation of what
either they wish wouldn't happen today
or maybe what's even happening today I
mean Jack and you're an autonomous is
kind of you know part past part future
in that you know she's kind of like
Robin Hood in some ways anti
but also looking deep for it in the
future but these are all events that are
happening now with you know medication
costs rising and sort of the the need
the urgency is sort of happening now and
yet you're kind of fantasizing about the
future so what do you see in that
continuum do you feel like you know
science fiction in the deep future is
really an expression of you know either
the author or the the audience's desires
for what's happening today or is it
something you know that you're really
trying to speculate on because if it's
so speculative I feel like the audience
couldn't recognize it and yet they
relate so viscerally here I mean I read
some of your thousand plus reviews and
people really relate you know as if
these are real people and yeah I mean I
I think of my work and I think of most
science fiction work as being
reflections of the present and so either
it's a way of grappling with issues in
the present at a distance or sometimes
it's really I mean like a lot of science
fiction authors like William Gibson
their work is set essentially at the
very edge of the present you know it's
something that is actually happening but
kind of just maybe 10 minutes out and
although not in his newer novels of
course he's he's also time-traveling in
those so so he's looking further in the
future so I that is my approach to it
certainly other science fiction writers
will say that that's not what they're
doing and of course any book that you
write is going to partly be a reflection
of your fears and hopes so I mean that's
why I have a an honorable pirate who is
trying to do good and hackers who are
trying to do good because that's kind of
my always been my perspective on it and
so yeah I mean it was funny because the
whole Martin shkreli scandal hit after I
was done with the book and it was
actually like right when the book was
coming out that he was kind of coming up
on charges and stuff and people kept
saying like oh it's about Martin shkreli
I was like well it is it's really just
about corruption in the pharmaceutical
industry and that's what drives our
scientist character jack to go to
rogue and to try to bring medicines to
people who can't afford it because the
system is so out of control mm-hmm yeah
I heard it son recently then in relation
to Martin shkreli I think that's how you
pronounce his name yeah let's go with
that I think he's in solitary
confinement now so I don't I don't know
if it makes a big difference but he's
not gonna be seeing this most likely
favorite podcast into the impossible so
no into the impossible as his escape
route also so yeah I heard said once
maybe it was by him or somebody
affiliate legal team you know michael
avenatti or somebody but it said
something like you know like they
shouldn't charge so much money you know
these pills cost 25 cents and someone
responded no the first pill cost two
billion dollars the next one cost 25
cents but but it's sort of disheartening
if some of these you know kind of
manipulations monopolies etc continue
into you know the Year 2044
21:44 is the novel prevents but so you
know I want to talk now a little bit
more about what your your next your next
book your next novel it really is as a
dive into the past and then the
nonfiction work you're working on that
you briefly mentioned last week and and
before we came on the podcast today as
dealing with their you know much far
distant past so I wonder if we can get
into those and for a little bit and talk
about the difference in writing kind of
historical you know almost fan
nonfiction and fan fiction in a certain
sense for the for the audience maybe you
can discuss a little bit of the theme of
your of your upcoming book which is
going to be out in September called the
future of another timeline and we'll
want to get you back on the podcast and
at UCSD for that but can you give a
brief description of that as you did for
the audience last week and then we can
get into the differences between writing
about past fiction and then future
fiction and and we can kind of explore
the differences between the two sounds
good
so future of another timeline is a
time-travel novel and and we can talk
about that too how do you write a hard
science time-travel novel turns out no
and I actually you know being a good
journalist I interviewed a couple of
physicists before I started and was
like okay so what's the most scientific
way I could do this and they both very
gently said this is a literary device
this is not science but I talked a lot
to Sean Carroll who's down there near
you guys he's a Caltech and he he gave
me some good ideas for how I could do it
that wouldn't be just egregiously
terrible
so there are wormholes
yeah and it's and and we I came up with
some stuff with Sean that you know could
could be true sort of physical sciences
but is obviously but is not something
that we know about today so so it's
about a group of activists who are also
professors at UCLA because the UC system
rules and they are trying to change
events in history to to basically make
to basically help vulnerable groups
people who they think need who you know
have been neglected historically or who
were suffering in the present so in the
case of the main character she's going
back to the 19th century trying to
change the culture at that time so that
abortion is legal because she lives in a
time line where abortion is not legal in
the United States and so for her this is
a very important political issue and so
she's trying to she's decided that
there's some events that occurred in the
19th century that kind of set us on this
course
and we're only in one timeline so she
changes the timeline everybody in the
United States would gain access to the
benefit or the not the benefit you know
if she screws things up the occasion so
so it was it was really fun to do the
world-building although I had promised
myself at some point that I would never
do a time-travel novel because they are
so tough and so there was a lot of
world-building at the outset where I was
trying to figure out all the timeline
shenanigans because they do change the
timeline she and her colleagues and so
so yeah and I had to do a lot of
historical research to the characters do
go to multiple different times but they
spend most of their time either in the
21st century or in the
19th century and so I had to look up
everything from like how much money a
woman who was working as a seamstress
might make in 1893 Chicago which luckily
there actually are records online
showing standard pay for actually
hundreds of jobs at that time I think
maybe partly because unions were being
organized quite effectively especially
in Chicago at that time so I think there
were a lot of efforts to kind of gather
that data and so so that they could have
a sense of who was working and what they
were making so so that was really fun
and frustrating I'm trying to do all
that research and you know it's funny
because I think when people are reading
the book they're not gonna be like oh
wow this what an accurate amount of
money that this character is making but
it's fun for me like again it's that
constraint I want the real world to have
constraints and or I want my fictional
world to have the constraints of the
real world so but creating a past world
is a lot like creating a future world
you know you have some guidelines but
there's a lot of missing information
even stuff from the late 19th century
there's tons of missing information
especially the characters I was writing
about which were like feminists and
belly dancers and sex activists and like
people who don't often make it into the
annals of history and and historians
have tried to unbury the histories of
some of these women but you know we're
not we don't have a lot to go on and so
so it's it's there's a lot of making
[ __ ] up you know just the way you do
with the future where you have some
information about where you think things
might go based on the way the world is
now but then you kind of have to fill in
the gaps and so with fiction I feel no
guilt at all I'm just like hey this is
fiction I'm just making stuff up
maybe they did this like I don't know
but when I'm doing nonfiction I have I
actually have a lot of guilt when I'm
trying to recreate life 9,000 years ago
during the Neolithic and like okay how
do I base you know I have to do some
speculation but I want every step of the
way every piece of speculation to be
based on something someone's founded it
dig something
that you know at least two or three
different scientists kind of agree on or
at least kind you know semi agree on and
that's yeah I mean I just I don't feel
like I can stray from the path as much
when I'm doing nonfiction yeah that
constrains I'm sure are much much
greater but then also you do have so
Andy weir is a I can't call him an alum
of sin UC San Diego because he never
graduated but you might go on to a good
career I'm not sure time will tell but
you know when he was here you know he's
really talking about how shocking in
some ways it was to do a hard science
fiction work and and then be mercilessly
attacked in some ways but also aided by
readers and another sense that they
could provide you know much more
information on you know smelting of
aluminum or for artemis or you know the
kind of communications codes that that
Watley uses in in the martian and you
know so there is also it seems like a
constraint for fiction authors as well
especially those of you who are trained
in the hard sciences or in science
journalism and sort of held to maybe
unfairly high standard but it must not
be completely liberating to Orkin
fiction because you know that you're
gonna have people that I mean like you
if you didn't go to someone like Sean or
somebody like oh that's completely
ridiculous but then actually doing the
work as you've done I think that gives a
greater you know imprimatur to their
realism if it will be you know for for
for readers to to to grab on to I want
to talk about a theme that comes up you
know somewhat in autonomous obviously
and maybe in the upcoming work as well
and that's you know graduate students
and kind of the the the positions that
the students you know we're talking
about almost slave like labor back in
the 1800s for women and you know a lot
of people feel like well graduate
students are kind of modern-day
indentured servants and in a certain way
and as I was telling you earlier our
building is called the serf building
that were in now science and engineering
research facility they couldn't come up
with a better acronym right now they
couldn't get su RF or you know something
unique to San Diego but but it made me
think about you know how
you view the process of the student you
know kind of teacher relationship and
that dynamic is very important to us
here in the research university like
UCSD in that you know there's kind of
this almost you know oral tradition of
passing on knowledge and and
collaboration between teacher and
student and and yet there's a very
different role between teacher and
students so I wonder you know can you
say something about your you know your
education I believe you were at the
night school at MIT is that correct yeah
so what was that like how did that
impact your writing and ultimately what
I want to get to from you is you're not
a you know a faculty educator and in the
sense that I am on a daily basis but you
know can you teach the skills that
you've acquired are they are they
teachable skills in the same way we can
teach electromagnetism or you know
general relativity are they skills in
the creative sense in the same creative
sense as as what what you do for a
living
yeah that's a really great question my
background is I have a PhD from Berkeley
in American Studies and which is an
interdisciplinary field so I did some
social science and some humanities work
and I originally thought that I was
going to be a professor that was like
basically what I'd wanted to be like
almost my whole life which is kind of a
weird thing for the high school student
one but that is what I wanted I really
want to be an administrator yeah did not
want to do that but and so when I was
graduating and going out on the market
it was at a time like now where very few
jobs were available particularly for
someone doing interdisciplinary work and
so I basically went out on the market
simultaneously to academic for academic
positions and for positions in
journalism and it was easier to get a
job in journalism and easier to support
myself and so basically as soon as I had
my PhD I did work for a little while as
an adjunct while I was kind of ramping
my career up as a writer but I've been
supporting myself on writing for my
whole adult life basically so and that
was because I failed to become a
professor I did do as you mentioned the
knight science journalism fellowship but
it might
which is kind of like a postdoc for
journalists and that was tremendously
helpful in kind of sharpening my my
knowledge of science because I was sort
of transitioning from writing about tech
to writing about more scientific topics
and I feel like as someone who was
teaching a lot especially when I was at
Berkeley I worked my way through school
basically by getting loans and teaching
I loved teaching teaching was my
favorite part of being in the university
other than the luxury of getting to just
study stuff that I liked and I really
missed it a lot that was the thing when
I transitioned into journalism that I
was most sad about was not having
students around to talk to and their
enthusiasm and their knowledge is so
incredible and so I try as much as I can
to incorporate pedagogy into my
journalism for sure and when I was
running io9 for many years it was very
similar to a classroom because there's
so many comments
so you'd wade into the comment forum and
it was like oh it's like a bunch of
people asking questions or having
debates and it really felt like that
kind of community where I could sort of
say well here's my opinion and here's
what I've learned and people would say
well here's what I've learned and here's
what I see and that's the best
experience in a classroom is when that's
happening and people our students are
empowered to talk about their own their
own discoveries
but you know I was very aware as a grad
student and as a postdoc of how abused
most of my colleagues were particularly
in the sciences I mean we were abused in
the humanities and Social Sciences just
because there was no money so it was
like well anyway at Berkeley let's be
honest just kidding I'm second and
because you are at Berkeley it's
Berkeley like especially abusive I'm
like teasing there are they're one of
our nemesis their arch-rivals yeah
you're not even on their radar like
Berkeley see Stanford is its nemesis
which is also kind of a sad anyway
whatever it's all sad where you
is our is like the best so I think we
can all agree this together we're strong
but yeah I mean it was super abusive and
like Isis Peschel II in the sciences
where people really had to like they
were dependent on their professors for
everything whereas we like I said there
was nothing at stake there was no money
like we weren't gonna get any fancy ass
like lab position so there were a few
people who who did have relationships
like that with professors like at a very
high level
you know we're dependent on them for for
fellowships and stuff and there was just
rampant abuse there was sexual
harassment there was just regular
harassment of just you know go get my
dry-cleaning kind of stuff I had a
professor who was trying to get me to do
data entry at his house and so I would
just go over to his house and like you
wander around in his robe and it was
like dude professors in Rome and
professors in robes this is it's like a
weird and it wasn't and I don't mean to
say that it was like a her awesome thing
it was just like creepy and
inappropriate like don't have your
student come to your house like it just
feels like you're a serpent anything and
it was creepy it's impossible to be in a
robe and not seem creepy yeah perfectly
nice guy but it was it was just you know
that kind of behavior assuming that the
student is just kind of at your beck and
call and and so that was I poured a lot
of angst about those experiences into
autonomous where one of the characters
is a grad student who's a robot who's
professor ports him to a printer so like
puts his brain into a printer and is
like oh one of these days I'll I'll hook
him up with an antenna so he can access
the network that way but for now he just
has speakers and you can talk to him and
it's it's pretty you know it's obviously
a metaphor so but I'm not theme you know
just so academia is imperfect most
systems are imperfect for sure and yet
we do have you know I always say you
know teaching is an act of love you know
hopefully purely platonic love you know
not in robes and and but it is you know
it's this expression of vulnerability
and and also you know asymmetry in some
sense you know you hope the teacher
knows more than the student right and in
some sense and that's natural
then in science I always point out the
word scientist in Russian at least as
far as I'm told
means a person who was taught really
conveys you know kind of this this
tradition now we're in that the ultimate
expression of science is to teach and
then the obligation and you know
corollary to that is that you have to
become a teacher and so we exhibit a lot
of that in the lab I'm nine graduate
students and and this is very important
to them the grad students or the
postdocs teach the grad students grad
students teach the undergrads they're
all kind of like force multipliers one
of the students brings you but the but
the ultimate you know kind of expression
of law is that you do the person leaves
right you know if you have children I'm
children now and you know kind of
looking nostalgically i back when they
needed me more in some sense but also
hopeful that they'll need me less in the
future right so when you when you've
been in that and I don't know if this is
something featured at night but you know
kind of the creative process and you
talk a lot obviously there's a lot about
human equivalent artificial intelligence
do you think that artificial
intelligence is a threat to the
traditional academic I mean what I do
has not changed substantively in the
thousand years you know basically a sage
on the stage you know talking to rapt
audiences you know that really hasn't
change but I think with the advent of AI
I mean why should students listen to me
and I mean you don't know me very well
but but why should those in the means
that have you know taking a class with
you know here's Galileo's dialogue on
two world systems right why should they
listen to me when an AI will soon
replace me and and be much more
authentic visceral and and maybe
authentic do you see that happening and
maybe taking away along so concomitant
Lee this oppression of students you know
because an AI hopefully won't have this
ability to oppress in the way that
you've unfortunately you know to
encounter well I think if future a eyes
if we ever evolve a human equivalent a I
if they're anything like the kind of
machine learning algorithms we have now
they're gonna have all the same problems
that we have right so they'll be a prep
though they'll be immersing their
students and making their postdocs you
know do their research for them for no
credit and stuff like that so I think
you know it's it's interesting because I
think what's happening with machine
learning in higher education right now
it seems like we're it would be going
would be toward just kind of aiding
professors like it might be something
where you would be replacing graders
like so you might have some kind of
algorithm that can grade a paper which
is kind of terrifying because what you
really want when somebody writes a paper
or a thesis or some kind of you know
analysis is you actually want a human to
kind of interact with it but I could
easily see it being I mean at a lot of
universities and I'm sure San Diego as
well you know there's these wieder
courses that are enormous and students
are producing you know essay questions
during you know answers to essay
questions and things and you have grad
students grading them and you know it
would be great if you could just replace
them with a machine right and just you
know scantron it kind of except now
you're doing scantron type stuff for for
actually you know written work so I
could see that happening will you be
replaced with a robot I don't know
you know maybe you'll have robot
teaching assistants like I said but like
I think I mean one of the things that I
think is really interesting about you
know writing from people like Brad
DeLong who's an economist who's thought
a lot about automation is that he he and
a lot of other economists feel that as
as we automate a lot of things we're
also gonna start hyper valuing human
labor around things like teaching and
caretaking and emotional labor that we
aren't really sure that robots can do
and so I could see teachers
I mean imagine that teachers becoming
actually more valued like and maybe paid
what they deserve to be paid that would
be kind of amazing so yeah I'm not too
worried about it right now but I could
see automation creeping in for sure
great so we just have a couple minutes
left I always like to get people's
opinions and maybe get to know them a
little bit better by asking
not so personal question but but in your
case I think I want to tie it to the mix
of genre subgroups that you work in
which is you know past fiction and
future fiction science fiction and that
is you know if somebody comes up to you
and tells you Italy I've got some good
news and some bad news
what do you want to hear first and why I
guess I want to hear the bad news first
because that way the good news will feel
as long as I don't have to just like
only hear one kind of news which would
be like reading Facebook I guess so I
think that makes you an optimist but I'm
not sure we can send it over to our
colleagues in psychology so I just want
to ask you know kind of a final question
in relation to these two works of
fiction and then as I said when you when
you're a book about ancient cities is
out I definitely want to have you
connect you to some of our wonderful
archaeologists here that work on a lot
of advanced imaging of archaeological
sites and that'll be I do have a
publication date or a notion of one that
will be out so it's coming out from
Norton and it probably out in 2020
that's our plan and my editor would
really like that if that were to happen
so I'm working with I mean so if you
could travel to either the future of one
of your novels or to the past which
would that which would you prefer to do
and and then I'll have a follow-up to
that but but would you prefer to go back
or they feel in the future you'd only do
one I guess I well because I write a lot
about our
Algie I think I would want to go to the
past and I would want to visit some of
the places that I'm writing about and
find out what the hell actually was
going on because there's so many
mysteries like that we just don't know
and it's super annoying so yeah I'd
really like to visit Cahokia which was
like a really big city about a thousand
years ago in southern Illinois it's it's
right near East st. Louis and that would
be like especially if I could actually
speak the language I would love to go
find out what they were up to
oh that's excellent well that basically
subsumes my next question which was you
know if you could go somewhere in
fiction and nonfiction all setting would
you go and and in your works and it
sounds like you'd like to go to Tokyo
funny I want to go to cook yeah if I
were to go to a place in a fictional
work I guess I mean in my upcoming novel
the characters they go to all real
locations but they go to Petra which is
called Rock mu in this version of
history because they're not colonized by
the Greeks so so yeah that would be
pretty fun that was in the Nabataean
empire in case you need to get some time
machine action yeah I like the Nabataean
Giants they're my favorite baseball team
[Music]
they were great it's like 2,000 years
ago they were on top of it global and
Lee it's been a real pleasure speaking
with you from up north I'm glad you made
the time and thank you so much for
coming down last week I hope we'll have
you down here again I'd love to yeah
thanks for having me on and sorry I
didn't want to out my editor don't worry
like are people gonna email him and be
like when is her book coming
we'll keep it and keep it just between
us our audience is growing but it's not
that take care bye bye
bye